Hello my name is David Brown and this is a pronunciation class. Hi David. I'm
fine thank you. How are you? I'm doing great. Thank you. Thank you. Welcome. Thank
Thank you, David. Are you ready for your lesson today? Yes. All right. All right. Well we
can practice this lesson that I see that you selected. We have this short
i sound and then this long e sound the short i sound is like /ɪ/ and then the
long e sound is like /iː/, right? Okay. This is important for us to master because it
can cause confusion for native English speakers and it's a really
commonly mispronounced pair. So we have some examples here. Some funny
examples. We have fill and feel, sit and seat, chip and
cheap. This one is bit. This one is beat, beat, ship and this one is sheep. This
is lid and this one is lead. All right. So we need to know the difference
between the /ɪ/ sound and the /iː/ sound, the /ɪ/ sound and the /iː/ sound. Okay. The
short /ɪ/ versus the /iː/ sounds. So this is what we'll practice in today's lesson. Two
different sounds. For example, what is this? This is ship*, ship, very good. And this
one, these are, these are sheep. These are sheep, right? Regular plural noun. So we're
looking at two English sounds that can be a little bit tricky but are very, very
important for clear speaking. We want to understand and be understood and this can
impact our comprehension. So it can change the meaning of words. We have this one
which is ship and this one which is cheap and that is just one example. So today we
have two objectives here. I'd like for you to listen to these objectives. Today you
will learn to hear the difference between /ɪ/ and /iː/ and say /ɪ/ and /iː/ more clearly. Let's
try this. Can you repeat it for me? /ɪ/. Now, /iː/, /iː/, /iː/, /iː/. Awesome. And so we have a little
activity here to practice. I said that you would need something like a stick and something
like a block. So I have a colored pencil and one of my daughter's blocks. Do you have
something? Okay, yes, yes, I have something. Okay, okay, like this. Alright, so let's
imagine that we have the /ɪ/ sound and it's like tapping a block. Okay, right? So tap /ɪ/
your block, say /ɪ/. Now we have the /iː/ sound which is longer. You can imagine that you have
your pencil and you're dragging it against something, /iː/, /iː/, /iː/. Good, /iː/. Alright, so
listen again, /ɪ/, /ɪ/ /iː/, /iː/. Notice that your jaw changes. So you have your tongue in a position
of your mouth higher for one than the other. It's all about the position of your tongue
in your mouth, /iː/ sound versus the /ɪ/, which is a little bit more relaxed. Okay. Do you hear
the difference? Yes. Okay, excellent. So the short i, the /ɪ/ sound is a little bit
different than the /iː/ sound, the /iː/ is more, and it's /iː/ with the tongue higher up. We have
the /ɪ/ sound with the jaw lower down, /iː/, you see my mouth, /iː/, alright? Okay, now you
don't want to say /ɛ/, and this is, we have the /ɛ/ sounds like lead (metal), and we have the /ɪ/ sound
like lid, and then we have the /iː/ sound like lead (to guide). And all of this depends on the position
of your tongue in your mouth. We have /ɛ/, /ɪ/, and /iː/. Repeat after me, /ɛ/, /ɪ/, /iː/   /ɛ/, /ɪ/, /iː/
/iː/. Very good. Alright, so there are some differences in these sounds depending on the position
of your tongue or jaw. So your mouth needs to be a little bit more open than with the
/i/ in Spanish. Your lips are relaxed, not smiling and not tight. So with the /ɪ/, it's like
this little bit more and it is just /ɪ/, /ɪ/, right? Not /ɛ/. The tongue is a little high, a
little to the front, and you'll need to relax your tongue a little. And it's a quick, a short
quick sound like a little tap in the block sound, right? Okay. Feel it, relaxed. So try
making this sound yourself. You can mute it. Try making this sound yourself again. Let
me hear you. Okay, /ɪ/, /iː/ And then /ɪ/, and /iː/, very good. Excellent. Okay. Alright.
And just a little bit of this practice can make a big difference. So now I want you to
show me... you can use a mirror or you can use the camera too. If you're too shy to use the
camera, that's okay if you want to use a mirror. So look at your mouth in the camera.
Okay. Like this. You can see /ɪ/, /ɪ/, /ɪ/, /ɪ/, not /ɛ/, but /ɪ/... /ɪ/ , and /iː/, /iː/, /iː/, /iː/, /iː/, /iː/, perfect.
Alright, so you have the mouth, which has the lips spread wide, like a rubber band, for
the /iː/ sounds, and it's high into the front, and you can feel a little bit of tension. So
we have the, this one, which is the /iː/ sound, this is /ɪt/, and this one is /iːt/, right? Right.
It's a long, stretch sound, like pulling something. So you can imagine for the /iː/ sound
that you have, like rubber bands pulling in the corner of your mouth for this one.
So you can see this in the image here. You have the, /ɪ/ sounds here, which is the center
in the front. The jaw is mid to close, and it's relaxed. And then the /iː/ sound is more spread
apart. It's a little bit more closed, and the tongue is a little higher up. That's a
good job. Alright, so let's practice some of these. Here's an activity for us. You've got
your block and your pencil or pen, or whatever, or stick. Okay. So when you, when I say,
or when, and when you say a word that has this short /ɪ/ sound, I want you to tap the block.
Okay. And then when it has a long /iː/ sound, and then I want you to slide your stick. You ready?
I'm ready. All right. So ship. Repeat, ship, ship.
Uh-huh. Ship. Ship. Get. Bed. Bed. Beats. Beats. Ship. Ship. And ship.
Sheep. Good. Sit. Good. Fill. Feel. Feel. Good. All right. We can practice a little bit more with this
/ɪ/ sound.